how are you doing today
good i like your bookshelves
uh thank you it's a distraction
no no i'm focused on you but i'm also
seeing the bookshelf and then proving
approving
i say uh thanks um i want to start with
uh uh i really laughed a lot and so i
just want to say thank you thank you for
making me laugh oh good good you're
welcome
right that's it that's all i have
congrats see you later thanks bye
no so
one of the interesting things about this
film is that you started filming right
as covid was sort of happening and then
you took a long break to come back to
make the movie what is that like making
your first feature
and in encountering this
insane
um so i we started shooting the first
two weeks in puerto rico for mexico
because the vacation takes place in
mexico and we wanted to get the most out
of it so we like it was a crazy
ambitious schedule and we thought the
weather might not be good but everything
went our way we were at uh it came off
great and then we were at the san juan
airport literally high-fiving each other
going we did it we got through the hard
part let's go to atlanta and finish it
it'll be so much easier from here on out
and we got a call saying uh there's a
pandemic
we're shutting down and
20 hours later i was sitting on that
couch just going what the hell just
happened
and uh
and then we thought it was going to be
for three weeks and it was like five
months or something and we resumed in
atlanta during the pandemic and we were
kind of one of the first movies to come
back
and their protocols we just kind of had
to figure it out as we went along and so
it was pretty crazy
yeah i can't even imagine um one of the
things the film does very well is it
it's very funny but it also has hearts
can you sort of talk about finding that
line in the editing room to make sure
that these are likable characters while
still doing some pretty crazy [ __ ]
that was very important to me and you
know all the
actors we had were actors i mean
i think rell's performance he has all
this depth to it and same with yvonne
and
john and meredith too there was just a
heart to it and sometimes people confuse
heart with sentiment it's not
sentimental i think but it has this like
dimension to these characters and
and in the end they're sort of all good
vibes which i i felt like was really
refreshing given the state of the world
um in a way when i was reading it it's
like bracing for this dark
darkness to emerge and it doesn't but
it's still crazy um but they're all
people
also you never know when you're casting
people how well the chemistry
chemistry's gonna be but the four of
them together are very good yeah oh i
couldn't believe it was like every day i
was like oh my god i'm so lucky
even despite the pandemic
um one of the things uh you obviously
have a drug scene
in the film and i'm curious what is it
like as a filmmaker trying to figure out
how do i want to shoot this that's going
to be different than other things and
sort of but also be familiar enough that
people understand
yeah that was really tough i think i
watched every drug scene that had been
in a comedy in the last 30 years
and
i just chose to pick something that was
a very specific style
and you know some of them
would try to recreate exactly what the
drug scene was and some would turn it
into a puppet show or some people would
be you would be in the normal world and
they would be acting crazy so i just
decided to just give it this very
specific style so at least you could be
there with them for it
100 i'm always obsessed with the editing
process because it's where it all comes
together um what did you how did the
film possibly get altered in the editing
room were there any big changes one of
the greatest things to happen to this
movie was
i hired an editor named evan hinke
and we were just it was like we'd known
each other all our lives and i didn't
know him at all and
he made it so much better we worked
together we just had the same view of
how to do this i don't even think we
ever had a major disagreement and
we just
were able to keep it moving
we had the same exact reactions to what
what what i'd shot and uh you know that
i feel just incredibly lucky to have
come across someone that talented
yeah
you uh you cut something good uh i gotta
wrap i'm just gonna say congrats i hope
it's a huge hit for you guys uh and
thank you for your time all right thank
you